This is a packet and bottle
of freeze-dried urine,
and the United States government
will sell it to you for $983,
plus shipping.
Which is perhaps the strangest sentence I've
ever started a video with,
but it’s true.
What's even stranger is:
that’s a pretty reasonable price.
These are two of more than 1,000
Standard Reference Materials
that are kept here at the National Institute
of Standards and Technology.
Here at NIST, we produce
Standard Reference Materials
or SRMs for short.
SRMs are super characterised materials that
our customers use
to make sure their measurements
on their materials and processes
are accurate and reliable.
When a customer buys one of our SRMs,
they get both a unit of material
and a certificate of analysis.
Each property, whether it’s a chemical constituent
or a physical characteristic of the material
is a certified property
and it's measured most accurately.
The certificate of analysis is just as important
as the material itself.
Without the certificate and all the information
that’s inside of it,
the SRM is just another bottle of stuff.
We have a variety of food materials in our
SRM catalogue,
so this is slurried spinach.
When you slurry the spinach, it's nice and
homogenous.
You sample a little bit from the top, it’s
the same as sampling from the bottom.
We also have our infamous domestic sludge,
from a waste water treatment process,
that has been dried, ground up, homogenised
into this nice, fine powder.
We take this material.
We certify various toxic elements
within the sludge,
that’s what it’s used for.
We also have the microsphere slide that contains
the space beads.
They're 10 micron-wide, polystyrene spheres
that were formed on
the space shuttle in zero gravity.
We have to store some of our more
sensitive materials in cryocooled conditions.
We have our peanut butter, right there in
a glass jar.
Oh, it’s crackling.
Then, we have our whale blubber,
organics in whale blubber.
This is actually whale blubber tissue from
a beached whale.
It's for tracking organic contaminants in
the environment,
and whales are the end of the food chain.
Every one of these reference materials has
to be exactly the same,
to an incredibly precise margin.
They’ll be used by people around the world
to calibrate and test machinery.
Now, other places make
reference materials too.
It's just that everything in this warehouse
has the US Government stamp of approval on it.
Now, just to be clear, the vast majority of
reference materials here are pretty dull.
They're for industrial processes, so they're
metal, or glass, or pure elements.
There are three types of bauxite: from Suriname,
Jamaica or the Dominican Republic.
There's even really precise mixes of gases
available,
along with some radioactive elements.
Sometimes, it takes us years to actually procure
a new material
that becomes an SRM a couple of years later.
We buy industrial products directly.
It comes from a different source each time
we make it,
but we make it the same way,
and we characterise it in the same fashion.
Either we determine the chemical composition
or its physical characteristics,
but we do that with accuracy.
In other cases, we have SRMs that are used
to determine how they break.
We measure over and over again,
with different methods,
to ensure that what we're measuring is the
true value in that particular material.
The material itself is not precise.
The measurements that characterise it
are precise.
So if you haven’t worked it out yet,
the reason that freeze-dried urine is one
of the reference materials
is because there are folks out there with
machines that test urine.
They're either testing for drugs,
so the Institute will sell you urine laced
with exact amounts
of the metabolites of cannabis or cocaine,
or they're testing for poisons and toxic elements.
So if you need to calibrate
one of those testing machines,
to make sure that the results are accurate,
then the folks here
are the ones you're going to call.
Thank you to everyone here at the National
Institute of Standards and Technology.
Pull down the description for more about Standard
Reference Materials
and about their work.